I just remember like even the costumes
putting them on and going what are we
doing right now like some things that
they make me put on I was just like what
is this lobster suit that I'm wearing
right now I didn't even know Selena
before that I wasn't as into Spanish
music as I am now I didn't know much
about her I knew that singer have been
killed and it was all over the news and
things like that and everybody was
talking about it but other than that I
didn't really know I just go right back
to the beginning of the movie in the
first day of shooting and really trying
to find the essence of who she was I had
done so much research and watched so
much tape on her and listened to her
voice and talked to her family and it's
like jumping off a cliff right you don't
know what it's gonna be like is the
first time I had ever played a real life
person she was an artist and she was
singing from the time she was 9 or 10
years old maybe younger and so that part
of it learning how she sang all her
mannerisms and how she danced and she
wasn't a trained dancer she was just a
natural performer she was just a great
performer so studying the tape of her
became really important the only way he
will know that I am NOT gonna give you
up is if we go out and get married right
now it was daunting but I remember just
kind of jumping into it headfirst and
and that first day everybody feeling
really great and it was just such a good
feeling made in Manhattan was really
tailor made for me by my producing
partner and the writers and you know we
made her from the Bronx we made her you
know a lot of the language and stuff is
stuff that I actually said and asked him
if I could say and put in there it was
just very organic to who I truly was and
it all worked out really really well
that's probably one of my favorite
movies I've done there was a part of me
that wanted to see what it felt
have someone like you look at me
Rafe was great I think he was so used to
doing kind of these these serious films
and the dramatic act tour and all that
kind of stuff but he was so endearing
and charming in this movie and it was
nice to see him bring his kind of acting
chops to something like that it just
elevated the whole piece him Bob Hoskins
Natasha Richardson and there's another
one where we had another amazing cast
around me and then where I felt like so
lucky to be in that movie out of sight I
just remember the trunk scene you know
kind of being locked in that trunk for a
day and filming that which was like a
seven and a half page scene what do you
want me to do scream I don't know it was
just kind of a style of movie at that
time it was crazy and it just had this
really specific feel to it kinda became
like a cult classic I think it didn't
get as much notice when it first came
out at the box office but now years
later I there's so many people like
yourself who told me that that was their
favorite film it's crazy you know Steven
was one of the most kind of I always say
clever I always think of clever when I
think of him I don't know why that word
comes to my mind he was just always
right up on the camera didn't sit back
at a monitor and watch he watched the
scenes close-up so if we were doing a
scene right here he'd be standing you
know sitting right where you were very
in it super woody if Steven made another
oceans film I wouldn't mind if he called
me up anaconda it was an amazing cast it
was kind of just like sci-fi crazy
monster movie Jon Voight and Eric Stoltz
and Ice Cube and Owen Wilson just a lot
of great guys we had a great time we
were down in Brazil for months for four
months
[Music]
we were glad it was a hit you know was
it that was a hit out of sight was it
there you go the cell dr. Catherine I
mean I remember doing that film and and
tarsem the director had such a he was
such a visual director he had such an
idea of what these bizarre kind of
images that he wanted to put in there
and kind of going inside the mind of a
killer and what that would look like and
what it would be like and I just
remember like even the costumes putting
them on and going what are we doing
right now like who am i right now he's
or in the side the mind of the killer
and I was like okay just try to make
everything feel like authentic and real
and that idea of going inside a killers
mind and how that changes you I feel
like who she is at the beginning of who
she is at the end even in that last
scene where she's by the car her life
has changed forever
[Music]
it was it was intense
I think more than anything the wedding
planner
I remember that you know I wanted to
make her super uptight which is not how
I am I'm kind of more of a loose streety
type of girl and she was so uptight and
tightly wound that's that's what I think
of when I think of Mary fury and not
leaving room for fun or anything else
besides work and or love you know but
all of those things being kind of a
protective defense mechanism so she
wouldn't have to feel anything or be
disappointed yeah there was a lot of
physical comedy in that film and I
hadn't really done much of it before but
I felt like I could do it and it was it
was so much fun it's actually my
favorite part of doing romantic comedies
now when there's a lot of physical stuff
where you get to kind of you know make a
little bit of a fool of yourself I love
that part shades of blue I think in a TV
series you really get to live that
character and it's a whole different
situation and if it's an interesting
character or a very flawed care
it really really helps you examine your
yourself and your whole life and I did
it for three years I played Harlee
Santos and it was such a complicated
complex role so many times I found
myself kind of like you know kind of
going okay here's here's what I'm doing
this is what I'm going to do they think
I'm lying but the audience doesn't know
I mean it was super complicated but
really good I mean in a movie you do the
character and you're kind of done with
it with TV if you get a great character
you get to live it and they almost come
becomes like a part of you like an alter
ego we talked about hardly like she was
a person you know you don't really do
that with movies it's like somebody like
we're not gonna see any more it was such
a demanding role and a demanding series
to do and I do so many other things so
in that sense I'm kind of relieved but
at the same time it was such a again a
great cast and I enjoyed so working with
Ray Liotta and the other people on the
show and he and I had such great respect
in chemistry for each other that you
know those things those things are
special moments you don't get you don't
have that with everybody in living color
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I auditioned for in living color in New
York they had a big open call and they
picked three girls to come an audition
against the big open called over here so
I think it was just kind of like a
gimmick I don't think they thought they
were gonna find somebody from whatever
well maybe they did but um I didn't get
it and then uh it was down to me and one
other girl and then they gave it to the
other girl and then Keenan came back and
said we made a mistake
we want you and I was like oh okay but I
didn't kind of believe him
and then sure enough you know made a
deal and I flew out and started living
in LA which was a great environment to
be around as my first kind of you know
taste of Hollywood and sets and all that
kind of stuff so it was because I was a
dancer up until then so it was it was
amazing they did their thing and we kind
of did our thing but it was it was nice
to be around and watch all the them
working on their sketch comedy and all
maybe that's where I got a little bit of
my romantic comedy stuff from you know
just watching them be so fearless a
second Maya
I mean Maya is very again like me to
Manhattan was something we produced and
something that was tailor-made for me
whereas that was like somebody at the
beginning of her life right this is
somebody who's kind of like in her 40s
and you know wondering if she's just
made mistakes and made the right choices
and kind of beating herself up and not
knowing if she deserves anything better
than what she has even though she's
smart and talented and driven why got
you in the door you got the job baby
you should shame let's go who's the kid
on the tail you're the you're the champ
it's not easy getting a job for a woman
your age Oh
watch me you know sometimes you just
think okay maybe my life is meant to be
this and she's about to give up and then
her whole life changes and he turned out
to be a really touching funny look at
life and I couldn't couldn't be prouder
of the movie I really loved it
Oh
you